hey youtubers is Charlie so some
pictures of Ben Affleck's Batmobile just
dropped the kid that took them even took
some pictures with himself in the
cockpit so let's take a look and see
what we all think as you can see it
looks pretty hardcore but I think it
says a lot about what Batman is going to
be doing in this next film by the way if
you're just finding me for the first
time I do DC movie and TV videos every
week so be sure to subscribe to get
everything because there's a bunch of
stuff coming this fall but you just feel
like this new Batmobile still has a lot
of the Christopher Nolan tumblr DNA in
it I'm starting to think that it looks a
lot like the Batmobile from the Arkham
Knight game the one that's coming out
next year you know slightly less
fortified than the tank but much more
aggressive and agile the story of Batman
vs Superman supposedly takes a lot from
the Frank Miller Dark Knight Returns
story so not going with the old-school
bat tank is a big departure but this
feels much more modern like it feels
much more practical the culture today is
all about shrinking cars down Frank
Miller's version was designed for
all-out open war this one seems much
more like a knife and the fact that it's
designed to turn around corners one of
the big problems with Christopher
Nolan's tumblr was that it had a really
hard time with corners just because of
those massive tires but going back even
further does anyone remember the Michael
Keaton Batmobile the Tim Burton one from
Batman Returns they actually had to use
a grappling hook to swing that around
corners I love how some of those movies
just throw physics out the window that's
why Christopher Nolan designed his to be
much more practical the tumbler Zack
Snyder's obviously continuing on that
theme so this car actually looks like
something you might run into in a street
show don't you just wonder if after this
movie's over Ben Affleck is gonna ask
Jennifer Garner for permission to buy a
custom Batmobile if just to keep in his
own garage I would be willing to bet
that this car might even be street-legal
one of the few Batmobiles including Adam
West's Batmobile that could make that
claim just for fun though let's actually
take a look at all the different
Batmobiles all the most popular ones if
you count like literally everything all
the comics all the media the video games
there have been almost 300 different
versions of the Batmobile I guess it
really doesn't matter when you're a
billionaire you can have as many cards
as you want though so here's all the
major versions starting with the first
one it was a red sedan it was just
called his car there wasn't anything
special about it it was just a regular
car it debuted in Detective Comics
number 27 they didn't start calling it
the Batmobile till issue 48
in issue 30 though they upgraded the
engine but it wasn't until Batman number
5 a separate comic in 1941 that they
made the body much sleeker darken the
color and that the bat hood ornament and
a fin the funny thing about that is is
the three pages after it debuted the
Joker forced it off a cliff but it was
totally back in the next issue I think
there was a joke in the Tim Burton
Batman about Bruce Wayne having more
cars than he knew what to do with but
then in 1944 the Batmobile was featured
on the cover of a comic for the first
time it was Batman number 20 this design
was so popular that it basically became
the default Batmobile for the rest of
the 1940s every once in a while there'll
be a Batmobile that's so popular that it
would believe from TV into the comics
usually it's the other way around
next of course came the very famous 1965
Adam West version it was made by George
Barris from a Ford future which was a
failed concept car they just never put
it into production he modified it to
give it a lot of the bad features but a
lot of the base design of the Batmobile
was already in that concept car later
during the 1973 Super Friends cartoon
they introduced a modified version of
that Adam West car they basically
straightened the lines change the hood
and added the batty cows on the doors it
was the first car to feature the yellow
Batman symbol on the car then of course
came the Frank Miller full-on assault
tank in the 1985 Dark Knight Returns
book in terms of size this is the
largest Batmobile ever it takes up three
car lanes the joke that he makes in the
story that Batman makes is that only
something not from this planet can
damage it of course talking about
Superman then in 1989 came the Tim
Burton design which lasted through both
of his films and also kind of influenced
a lot of later designs the body was a
complete custom fab built on top of a
Chevy v8 they made some major
modifications like adding the jet
turbine to the design but they did keep
a lot of the 1930s influence with the
big tail fins if you remember the 1989
Batman series that came after their
Batmobile took a lot of Tim Burton's
design and incorporated a lot of others
the animation made it a lot easier for
them to fudge the laws of physics so
they were able to combine a lot of
different elements from previous
Batmobiles in the concept like the idea
of jet turbines and turning corners
really fast then in 1995 Batman Forever
modified the Tim Burton design just to
make it look like it actually had ribs
more like an actual bat they made the
cockpit smaller added highlights in a
lot more gadget Ori and a much larger
fin this was basically the beginning of
the Joel Schumacher era then a couple
years later in the Batman and Robin
movie they push the cockpit back even
further accentuated the grill and added
lights basically everything almost
everything on the car lit up
supposedly they wanted the car to feel
like it had this larger-than-life
presents when ever it was on screen like
it was an actual character in the movie
if you guys want to have some fun and
blow some time listen to the commentary
track on Batman and Robin Schumacher
basically spends the entire movie
apologizing then in 1995 whenever they
started the new animated series they
completely redid the car to make it just
way simpler that series only ran till
1999 but the design of that car was used
in the comics so it was actually really
really popular so now we move into the
modern Batman era where everything is
like post superhero so this is like
stuff that you might actually find in
the real world
in 2005 eight years after Batman and
Robin Christopher Nolan introduced the
tumbler a modified army vehicle made the
jump canyons and lay bridges they made a
bunch of modifications to it across the
Dark Knight trilogy like giving it
remote control features and adding the
Batpod motorcycle but all in all this
became like the most popular Batmobile
ever not necessarily the most iconic but
probably at least in the last 10 years
the most popular design so then we move
into the Arkham games which were
actually starting to make more money
than the movies the first Arkham Asylum
game in 2009 introduced a slightly
modified Tim Burton Batmobile it wasn't
too crazy with gadgetry and weapons it
was just a really classic design the
most recent Batmobile to be seen not
including sac Snider's is during the
Arkham Knight game it's not going to be
released till 2015 but as you can see
the design combines a lot of the urban
manoeuvring features with the assault
weaponry of the tank from Frank Miller's
1985 comic right now I still totally
love the tumbler but my favorite
Batmobile is probably going to be the
one from Arkham Knight next year the one
from the new game my favorite animated
one is still from Batman the Animated
Series but now it's your turn let me
know in the comments what is your
favorite Batmobile like I said there's
almost 300 it's almost like Batman has a
3d printer and he just prints cars out
every year on a related note don't you
think it's interesting that Stephen
Amell does
have a green arrow car on arrow on that
show I'm totally glad I don't think it
would work with the tone of the show and
the look they're going for he does have
a pretty sweet motorcycle though I would
actually like to see them do a joke
about Felicity's van being their
official team arrow car just like their
big cargo van during season two she ran
over Summer Glau at it would it be great
if they just never fixed the dent that
she left and anytime someone made fun of
her everyone just looked at the dent and
got really quiet I just like the idea
that Felicity might threaten someone
with running them over with the van
right now on Batman versus Superman they
still got a bunch of filming left to do
but there are more and more pictures
posting from behind the scenes there was
an image of Jesse Eisenberg with this
weird Lex Luthor hair it's not
guaranteed or anything but it might be
what he looks like during the film Jason
Momoa has pretty much all but confirmed
he's playing Aquaman - I don't think I
did a video about it but Zack Snyder
basically called into a radio station
defending the idea of Aquaman he wasn't
confirming the character was in the
movie or anything but later Jason Momoa
would not stop talking about how excited
he was for the movie during interviews
so do not be surprised if Jason Momoa
shows up in the movie I mean it's
probably a really small part but it is
like the worst kept secret I haven't
really enjoyed his leading roles quite
as much you know like Conan but I think
he can do really well in an ensemble so
right now I am working on an Avengers 3
guardians of the galaxy video for
tonight supposedly there's some really
interesting contract renegotiations
going on behind the scenes with Dave
Batista's Drax character so I'll explain
what's going on with that so be sure to
subscribe to get it
also add an annotation right here
whenever I post it that'll probably be
tonight
and you can click here to learn about
all the fall TV shows and movies and
stuff and I'm doing I just posted a huge
fall channel trailer thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you